so obviously you know episode 14 was
very much the clouds it was kind of a -
j-rok can you believe this today I'm
d-roc you crushed that today was look I
mean this is day in the life of
entrepreneur like sometimes you get to
fly around and run into LinkedIn and see
billionaire sports owners like Steve
Ross and it's one of those days in other
days you're just sitting in the office
all day on a President's Day weekend
when everybody else is off and you're
grinding through meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting after
meeting you have to just bet on your
[ __ ] core strength that is the game
like I'm about like I'm even stopping
myself I'm just about to give you advice
of like don't listen to Paul Graham or
me but the truth is maybe that is how
you dominate like like I wasn't capable
of like like I wish I could take more
from other people like it's an easier
I'm going the number one thing that you
can do at this point your life whether
it's this app or [ __ ] this is how
you're gonna win is you just need to
decide what's the one thing that you're
better at than anything else that you're
better at and you need to become the
extreme version of that that I believe
more than anything
you're creating game is your creative
game it's like the talent you were born
with and the practice you've deployed
against it but 3/16 yourself amount like
EQ HR like building the equity because
you know Karen loves Kanye and then
making a Kanye joke when Diageo is
giving tough feedback and it's a tough
moment that's the [ __ ] magic in a
world where I know how creatives are
judged everywhere else I'm not waiting
for your big thing I'm trying to see if
you've got all those other little things
because they lead to consistent big
things yeah it's really I appreciate you
saying that
like I mean a lot of you're right a lot
of people just don't say that again I
don't like when you tell the people you
care you actually care about them
because like people don't hear it enough
like sometimes you have to do that
that's how this thing scales that's why
we have what we have now that's cuz it's
not something written on the wall yeah I
know and that's its religion over tactic
yep got it and it really does manifest
itself in the work
it's a very intimate event you know what
it's a very interesting day I'm in a
very kind of like deep I'm in a funny
mood I'm in a deep / competitive mood
I'm pissed about that fan a fan is just
thinks that I all I talk about now is
that I cannot work them and I don't
bring them value anymore and then I'm
not doing anything tangible like the
early version of me yet literally his
next post was a carbon copy of the way I
promote and do a tactical like getting
people to follow me on snapchat and it
hurts my feelings that I'm not doing a
good enough job that he can't see that
he literally in one tweet called me out
without using my handle but I know what
it stands for and the next post is a
post of me of him doing my snapchat step
one step two step three thing I created
that's tactical and so it's got me in a
bad mood because I care I never will
take for granted one like I hate when
people like who cares it's one phone
cares it's one I care can you give me my
next meeting
hey guys how are you
things are really good excited to get on
the phone I'm excited to share a couple
things on my mind like I'm I'm
personally very excited about the
narrative of creating the way to do this
right and I think there's a lot in the
same way that Oreo gets disproportionate
for that one tweet six years later I
think when this works if it if you guys
feel comfortable with it I think I can
single-handedly put this on the map for
you guys and us and I'm excited about
that I just want to make sure we're
aligned on that here's my theory and
here's what I want to do I basically
want this one I'd be campaign to be the
campaign of the year I want to invent
Facebook advertising it's hard I would
have never eaten popcorn anywhere else
Oh
homuth home is bad home is bad
it's because you're not busy you're not
doing things I'm a different mindset I
need more fruit and vegetables it's
really simple I will call you during
this meeting and put you on speaker
you'll get a shout out
but you minimally have to buy 40 books
on Amazon right now because we're busy
here and you've got to send in the
receipt it needs to be the receipt that
you just bought 40 books and put your
phone number in it I'll call your ass on
speaker
you'll get your shoutout well Jam nope
this is only live but i'm hope you enjoy
hope you're enjoying episode 15 somebody
just did it PayPal voice is a Cara or
Cara don't find out
hello hello this one Oh Kara yeah this
is Gary Vaynerchuk thank you so much for
get on the computer live so what are you
gonna do with the 50 bucks
Oh my agent so I felt this huge social
media following and when I do that I do
marketing for a title company so my
favorite episode of the enemy shows
episode 35 his agent called me and asked
what you would do if you are an agent
and so you said I would take like the
ten miles around my office and I'd go
get all the stores and I would write
about those stories and I keep this in
my class all the time but I swear I'm
single-handedly responsible for getting
you one it's too much more power right I
love you thank you so much I'm so so
happy done and thank you so much for
buying the book right now it means a lot
to me you're welcome thanks for calling
okay I'm great night Oh India bye you
got another one this is fun there's
phone calls Oh Eddie it's not your dad I
know I said Eddie not dad I know you're
I mean I remember how are you brother we
got more votes for call you have three
more
this is like the rail dar sit the rail
that our meeting who's this Michael I do
I'm doing super well mate how are you
very well
Nicholas hey I'm Jerry things a good man
how are you pretty good man I'm tough
pretty cool well I was watching you on
that it looks awful
whoa you're glad ticket yes that was a
good decision this is so fun so you know
some days are just this there to grind
you're just in it day in and day out
hour after hour minute after minute in
the meetings and it's not glamorous it's
not getting the accolades of selfies and
and being there it's not the big time
meetings with the biggest companies in
the world or the titans of industry it's
just hardcore dirt right you know just
grinding the operations having meetings
meeting with people about their careers
dealing with issues integration running
a company you know I hear a lot of
people saying like oh like it's all you
know it's the speaking in the books and
stuff like this is my day to day my day
to day you know 70% of the time is just
hardcore dirt work you know getting your
hands dirty putting in the work having
the meetings doing what an executive
guns which is architect map you know
orchestrate things that scale and so I
enjoy tonight I enjoy as much as I enjoy
going to LinkedIn or as much as I enjoy
hanging out with a five billion worth a
sports owner and thinking about my
future and thinking about the accolades
and the attention and all that I get
equal if not slightly more value out of
putting in the actual work that has
allowed me the attempt for the audacious
goals that I've created for myself
cool
you
you